Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and for my bonus
Marvel video this week we need to talk about
the Death of SHIELD and how it affects potential
stories for Captain America 3 and Avengers
Age of Ultron.
It all ties into something Kevin Feige said
recently.
He talked about how they wanted the Avengers
to face this new Ultron threat without the
benefit of an international organization like
SHIELD.
The really cool thing is that Marvel has already
done a big story like this, called Secret
Avengers.
Real quick though, if you’re finding me
for the first time.
I do bonus Marvel videos every week.
Normally on Tuesdays, be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave me suggestions
for future topics in the comments.
So let’s ask a really big question.
What happens to Captain America and The Avengers
when SHIELD doesn’t exist anymore?
First let’s talk about the end of Winter
Soldier.
Chris Evans and Nick Fury said two very important
things.
Well, they actually said the same thing essentially.
They’re going to conduct new missions on
their own, off the grid.
SHIELD having been the Grid so to speak.
Nick Fury was headed after the remnants of
HYDRA and Captain America was going after
Bucky to try and rehabilitate him.
The same is true for the rest of the non-HYDRA
people that left to join other teams, like
Maria Hill joining Stark Industries and Sharon
Carter joining the CIA.
This mirrors some of the things that happened
in the comics in the wake of the Civil War
storyline.
After which Norman Osborn took over SHIELD
and rebranded it as HAMMER.
Then came Dark Avengers and Secret Avengers.
Secret Avengers was essentially the story
of Captain America putting his own team together.
Here’s where it gets more interesting as
it applies to a potential Captain America
3 story.
The first Secret Avengers team he assembled
included Beast, War Machine, Valkyrie, Moon
Knight, Nova, Black Widow, Sharon Carter,
and Ant-Man.
So right off the bat we have to toss out Beast
because FOX copyright and they haven’t introduced
Valkyrie in the movie universe yet.
She could always be replaced by Sif since
she’s also an Asgardian.
Moon Knight is someone that hasn’t made
it into the movies yet either.
Nova could always come via Guardians of The
Galaxy.
All the other members we’ve met or will
meet before Captain America 3 is released.
Next big question, realistically if they did
Secret Avengers as the plot of Captain America
3, what would the actual team be and what
would they be doing.
Remember, the movie is going to come right
after Ant-Man in 2016.
So we’ll have had Guardians of the Galaxy,
Avengers 2 and Ant Man.
So a lot of new characters and potential stories.
Let’s talk roster.
Captain America can only pick from existing
Avengers and other characters we’ve met.
Based on the original team here’s what we
could see.
Don Cheadle as War Machine, Jaimie Alexander
as Sif, someone from the Nova Corps in Guardians
of the Galaxy, Scarlett Johansson as Black
Widow, Emily Van Camp as Sharon Carter and
Paul Rudd as Ant Man.
Now let’s get a little more realistic and
shorten that list a little.
Casting that many actors would make it feel
like a real Avengers Movie, and it’s supposed
to be a Captain America movie.
So let’s just take Black Widow, Sharon Carter
and Lady Sif.
Wouldn’t that be crazy.
Captain America and a badass team of Marvel
Women.
It would be like Charlie’s Angels.
I don’t think they’re going to do that.
But it’s fun to imagine.
I’d swap Sif for Paul Rudd just to balance
it out.
Now let’s talk plot.
In Secret Avengers the villains evolve into
the Masters of Evil, which I think we’ll
see in some form in the movies eventually.
There are a ton of volumes in that comic series,
but in general since Captain America is a
very earth based super hero.
I think any of the characters or story arcs
they pull out will be more like Winter Soldier.
More Bourne Identity than spaceships and aliens
like some of the other Marvel movies.
The takeaway from all this Winter Soldier
SHIELD stuff is that Captain America will
be putting his own covert team together and
his next mission will be them traveling around
dealing with Masters of Evil, more HYDRA and
possibly getting tied up in whatever Nick
Fury is up to.
He’s actually a big part of the story in
Secret Avengers.
So if you want to learn more just read that
comic.
Let’s move on to what all this means for
Avengers 2.
Because like I said Marvel implied that SHIELD
would still be on extended smoke break when
Ultron comes.
We already know a lot about what’s going
on in the movie and who the big characters
are.
We even saw Captain America and Hawkeye’s
new suits and Iron Man’s new Armor.
We even know what Ultron looks like.
But the destruction of SHIELD opens up a lot
of possibilities for how the story will progress.
If they stick with Secret Avengers we’ll
get to see Captain America traveling around
to everyone from the first movie to get them
back on the team.
And in case it wasn’t clear after Thor The
Dark World, Thor is living on earth.
So all of the Avengers are closer than ever
before.
And Stark Tower will be finished.
We saw a peek of it during Winter Soldier.
That means the real problem won’t be making
them all play nice, it will be finding the
resources to fight Utron.
If only there were a billionaire industrialist
playboy philanthropist nearby who just hired
SHIELD’s former second in command.
So they will have all of Iron Man’s resources
at their disposal, but if Ultron is capable
of co-opting electrical systems we need to
think about how that will affect all the Stark
Tech.
We did see the Hulkbuster fighting Hulk in
the concept footage.
It’s possible that could be Ultron just
using the suit.
And then there’s the birth of Vision.
Ultron creates Vision in the comic books,
but we don’t know if they’ll do it that
way in the movies.
And if Tesseract Energy is going to play a
role.
If you didn’t catch the Baron Von Strucker
reference during Captain America, Loki’s
staff and tesseract energy were responsible
for Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch getting
their powers.
That’s a big departure from the comics,
but I have a feeling the birth of Ultron and
Vision will be loosely related to tesseract
energy interacting with Stark Tech.
Let me know what your answer is, how is Stark
Industries going to step in and fill the SHIELD
void when Avengers 2 gets here.
Also since it’s Wednesday I’m also working
on a bonus Arrow video.
I’ll mostly be talking about the Flash crossover
happening next week and the finale.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
You can click here to watch it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And you can click here for my Winter Soldier
Review.
Thanks everybody, see you tonight.
And oh yeah...Hail Hydra!